fighting games have this little piece of
black magic at their core that makes
playing them online not only possible
but legitimately great but before we had
it the future of fighting games online
looked extremely Bleak for the most part
if you're playing like a game that's
popular you know playing online is fine
most of the time you don't have the same
kind of issues that you see in fighting
games with delay based netcode a lot of
times it's pretty crazy the craziest
part the person who came up with this
revolutionary idea did it in his spare
time because a port of his favorite
fighting game completely sucked online
it's not a stretch to say that rollback
netcode has completely changed the way
that we think and most importantly feel
about playing fighting games online I
want to wake up and not have to think I
hope any of the three or four fighting
games come out next year have good net
code I'm literally asking for the game
to be playable online so how the hell
did it all happen and why did it take so
long
ate the stand block and made me cry dude
this lag straight up
[Applause]
that's right baby now I'm the guy in the
nebulous green screen box who's here to
talk about nerdy so take a hike
Counter-Strike valorent even you League
of Legends because today we get to talk
about some other games for a change for
decades fighting games couldn't be
played seriously over the Internet that
wasn't always a big problem because live
and in person was exactly the way that
fighting Gamers preferred it but modern
games need online play the problem was
that fighting games just hadn't kept up
for me overall Street Fighter 5 netcode
is not 10 out of 10 but I would not have
any qualms about saying that was a real
match where it felt like the real game
wow you cannot you can't even write this
look at me I try to show it for you
Capcom and look what you do
what the
I don't know if anyone saw that did
anyone catch that today a game that
doesn't have good net code might as well
be dead on arrival and thankfully for
all of us Capcom finally implemented
quality rollback netcode in Street
Fighter 6. now you can play matches
against people who are pretty far away
and still have a stable experience as we
discovered in our review of the game I
went into one of the busiest Asian
region lobbies and played against two
players with over 200 paying that were
likely in or around Japan sure it was
noticeably worse than a local n a
connection but it was honestly better or
on par with anything that I would have
expected back in Street Fighter 5. in
five or six games I dropped less than 10
frames to Japan that's not good net code
it's witchcraft it's no wonder that
people were celebrating like the
Galactic Empire was finally defeated but
Capcom took a long time to get here
Capcom and other developers didn't
really focus on online play until very
recently and things were pretty bad how
insane is it that there's not a fighting
game in 2019 with perfect netcode a
working Lobby system that just makes
sense really good training like a robust
training mode with good features and a
solid tutorial mode these are all
standard things that fighting games
should contain in 2019. so let's take a
look back historically fighting games
have excelled in two huge Arenas at the
arcade and on home consoles the arcade
was a central place to play the game so
networking wasn't a requirement if you
wanted to update an arcade machine you
did it the old-fashioned way but by the
late 90s it was a lot more common to
play fighting games online 1998's net
fighter appears to be the earliest
internet compatible fighting game at
release but as the years went on more
and more games got online play
unfortunately it was pretty laggy that
didn't sit well with fighting game
competitor and developer Tony Cannon who
realized that with arcade starting to
disappear online play might be the
genre's lifeline but he also understood
how different fighting games felt online
by introducing lag it immediately makes
the game not worth playing especially
for someone like me think about me and
all of you guys like you're in the
arcade you're building this skill for
like 10 years and then you're trying to
play a game online that just throws it
all out because your timing all changes
more than real-time strategy or even FPS
fighting games online had to feel like
the same thing everybody already knew
and loved so how did our boy Tony solve
this problem well I think I'll let the
guy who actually knows what he's talking
about handle this one and now the guy
who actually knows what he's talking
about
wait I still have to do this bit too so
when it comes to Ping the round trip
latency of your data from you to your
destination some games are simply more
demanding than others fighting games
measure things in frames there are
generally 60 of them every second and
being just one or two frames late can
create a massive connectivity problem as
Canon explained at Evo 2017. 60 times a
second they're reading your joystick and
then they're running just a tiny bit of
game State you know once this 60th of a
second and then they're rendering the
frame over and over and over again right
and so the problem was at that let me
read the joysticks step it has to get
the remote packet over the network at
first glance this seems like a pretty
serious problem if the two game clients
have to basically shake hands with each
other or a server 60 times every second
just to make sure they're on the same
page then the connection stability is
going to be incredibly important if
there's any reason why there's packet
loss or a drop in the quality of the
connection you will have a bad
experience it will be noticeable and if
there's Mega loss the game will chug and
freeze these games supported multiplayer
but they lagged like because uh
essentially when you played someone the
longer it take to transmit traffic over
the network the more the game would lag
it seemed plausible that eventually
Network speeds could support this model
but the fighting game Community didn't
have time to lose this was pre-2009 and
the feeling was that fighting games at
least in North America were going to die
with arcades so instead of waiting Canon
developed good game piece out a program
that used an existing emulator final
burn Alpha to run his new strategy for
handling netcode the basic idea was
simple at its core but revolutionary for
the genre What If instead of trying to
synchronize every frame you just guess
and if you guess wrong you catch the
player back up this was the only way to
make anything work with zero frames of
latency if you really need to simulate
and you don't have both inputs well I
guess you just have to simulate the
secret saw Us in the formula was that
the netcode kept tabs on the possible
outcomes of the actions on screen
allowing the actions to be re-simulated
in the background thus the name rollback
so ggpo will ask the game hey game could
you go back a few frames and then
re-figure out what happened like sort of
re-stimulate this had other consequences
like for example sometimes you missed
out on a couple starting frames of an
animation you should have been able to
see but that was obviously way better
than the alternative constant lag input
delay and synchronization problems that
interfered with the ability to play at
all it's not hyperbole to say that
Canon's idea changed fighting games
forever he started working on it in 2006
and got to demo it to Capcom later that
year rollback style netcode went on to
be implemented in a number of fighting
games and in 2019 Canon made ggpo open
source under the MIT license but even
though we had a great solution as early
as 2006 we didn't have the same sense of
urgency until 2020 and that was the guy
who actually knows what he's talking
about so rollback worked remarkably well
but implementing it into existing games
was a lot of work just to give you guys
a sense of the scope of what we were
the time we invested in shipping this
thing was about 4 to 12 concurrent
Engineers for nine months
roughly seven or eight man years of work
for the initial release and then ongoing
support is part-time work for about six
Engineers another realm chose to
implement rollback for Mortal Kombat 10
and Injustice 2. but you can see why
some companies might have been a bit
hesitant the bottom line is this was
expensive was it worth it the fans said
yes but the devs well it wasn't exactly
the sexiest addition to their games plus
at the moment a lot of players had some
other option either arcades or maybe
locals which had a massive Resurgence
along with Street Fighter 4's genre
defining popularity Street Fighter 5
launched in 2015 with a pretty Bare
Bones offering and eight frames of input
delay on PS4 depending on the density of
the player base where you lived playing
online could be a nightmare in
particular one voice stepped up say jam
a legendary fighting game commentator he
was Unapologetic in his criticism of bad
net code when it comes to fighting games
you know what I want I want to wake up
and not have to think I hope any of the
three or four fighting games come out
next year have good net code I'm not
asking for a battle pass I'm not asking
for 34 million dollar prize pool I'm not
asking I'm literally asking for the game
to be playable online
that's all I want is something so small
and those criticisms necessarily
extended to Capcom because Street
Fighter 5 had plenty of problems some
games had decent netcode from older
games like Killer Instinct to newer
games like Guilty Gear strive but sejam
was clear we needed to start demanding
better from fighting games and
especially Capcom this is the problem
with fighting game fans you guys are all
already making excuses don't do that
demand that the fighting games you play
are better Ki in 2013 had netcode that's
incredibly good why is it that not every
fighting game company on the planet
since then has said that is a solved
solution when ggpo came out why didn't
people think to themselves that is
solved Street Fighter 5 had in-house
rollback net code but the implementation
was really bad so bad in fact that the
fighting game Community once again took
it upon themselves to fix it in 2020 a
fan patched by user altimore corrected
one of the issues with the net code that
had persisted for four years and then
made it available to download fan
reception was positive meanwhile
capcom's poorly implemented version of
the same fix improved things but just
barely in many ways the fighting game
communities patience with Capcom and
Street Fighter 5 had run out and the
company was out of time over the years
Street Fighter 5 had become a good
fighting game offline but with the
pandemic Upon Us suddenly online play
was the only option including for Capcom
Pro Tour events and it was a terrible
one
spectating has been halted what do you
mean do you have any thoughts about how
you are gonna prepare for that kind of
extremely Talent dance tournament again
nah I'ma just play guilty here I I don't
like the lag so I'm not going to force
myself to play I love the game yeah the
game is amazing but online it's just not
good and it just totes me to I'm sure
y'all know I'm senior I'm sure everyone
sees my tweets all the time so I can say
I have a lot of sympathy you know if I'm
if I'm honest with you people are like
uh oh what's gonna happen to punk the
difference is is you know they don't
hire a punk the funny things is that a
lot of people know that I don't do CPT
events anymore because Capcom is grumpy
about me talking about the netcode or
saying hey you guys probably should have
an lcq for Capcom cup you know but the
story has a happy ending as you already
know Capcom did the right thing and
hopefully LED the way for innumerable
fighting games to come frankly it's hard
to imagine two games more different at
launch than Street Fighters 5 and 6.
five had almost no single player
offering six has a full open World
experience that eases you into fighting
games in fact everything about the game
is just better including thankfully the
netcode the net code was very very good
uh I play people from Mexico UK those
are three bar connections according to
the game but I really did not notice an
issue if anyone had told me that was a
um like a US match versus Europe I would
not have believed it we have a new
Street Fighter game that has both
well-implemented rollback netcode and a
robust and easy Lobby system it's about
damn time but it's also more critical
than ever because we have a new
generation of players who wants to grind
online and we now know Tekken 8 is going
to have rollback though obviously we
still need to see how it actually works
the future looks brighter than ever for
fighting games and Tony Cannon isn't
done bill yet he and his brother Tom are
both part of the development team for
project L right games upcoming tag
fighter so yeah this is a victory for
fighting games but it's important for
developers to realize that this is only
the beginning say jam who got back into
capcom's good graces in time for Street
Fighter 6 was right we shouldn't accept
less you should ask for so much better
than that you're a human being why the
would you waste your time making
excuses for people who are selling you a
product that should be better than that
how do you figure how do you guys feel
about those
I can't
I can't judge my own acting
all right
wow thanks thanks for the vote of
confidence I appreciate it